earlier in the day I got I got in a fake
fight with Mark Wahlberg for no reason
you ever do that you're just like dude
what if I was like working with Mark
Wahlberg on a movie and like he's like
started giving me attitude I'd be like
dude I'm not gonna stand for that like
in my head I was just at drinking coffee
I was on my way to some [ __ ] coffee
shop in Albuquerque that's all painted
white outside that's way too bright
hey Albuquerque never paint anything
outside white do you know why it
reflects the Sun and do you know that is
1000 degrees dude I feel so ridiculous I
parked my car by the way I got a killer
[ __ ] red Honda rented it and I parked
and I went to the coffee place and there
was like this like outside kind of like
mulish area and it was all painted white
and I was like looking for the coffee
place that I looked up on Yelp and I
just looked like Clint Eastwood trying
to do anything in his life
I don't know have sighted em bring
sunglasses of course and oh and the
misters werever dude there was this
burger place next to the [ __ ] coffee
place and there were these me there was
like an outside seating area and people
were sitting there and it was just
misters so many so much water that they
were just eating burgers in a lake and
people are out delivering bro dude I'm
sorry but Albuquerque has it nailed they
have it nailed down because who the [ __ ]
would want burgers outside at 12 p.m.
when it's a hundred and two degrees out
head Hey I'll skip the meal hey you want
to eat sure where you want oh we're
gonna go eat burgers in hell
what yeah but there's a let it's in a
lake basically I'll skip the meal do it
hey catch me at dinner was I talking
about Mark Wahlberg yeah so I got a fake
fight with Mark Wahlberg cuz I don't
know why I think he was like when I was
I was in my head and I was just like
kind of getting the coffee and I was
reading the script and to see how much
it changed from the first draft and then
in my head Mark Wahlberg like well I was
doing a movie with him and he was just
like hey man he'll talk to me like that
or someone else I got even mean to do
that like and he was like oh
you know he was like we're not gonna be
doing that to me and then I was like aw
dude yo yo hey I'm not that guy like
that's what I was saying in my head
[Laughter]
and I know he liked boxes and [ __ ] so I
was like okay fine fine [ __ ] fight I
don't even give a [ __ ] dude if you want
to fight fight me I don't what the [ __ ]
do I care and I had some cool insults I
have I have him locked in my head in
case he has her give her gets in a
[ __ ] fight with me I'm not gonna tell
him on the podcast design guy come up
with new ones if it really happens or is
you use them and they'll be like fan
faves bro I got insults with so many
stars in my head just in case and then
just in case somebody has a camera on me
lies the LIA keep coming up with these
[ __ ] cool things before fights he's
like the real Arnold Schwarzenegger
remember in [ __ ] the movie uh what
the [ __ ] erase erase erase erase ur
eraser where he plays it I think it's a
racer he's in a movie called eraser Ivan
gets rid of looks at me and says eraser
like it's [ __ ] The Godfather and and
he's like and and there's this one part
where any clones himself so it's about
Arnold Schwarzenegger cloning himself
and and there's two parts there's I
don't know if one of this one may not be
an eraser but he shoots the alligator
that's attacking him Hey and he says you
luggage which is dope and now I can't
use that because if it gives an
alligator talking I have to think of a
new one but and then there's one that
self essa forced that it was
unbelievable so he'd they clone it
clones himself and [ __ ] and he and they
clone him and he realizes it or
something and at the end he says he says
to the guy who's like the head bad guy
he's like well into the case he should
have you should have cloned himself and
then the guy says why is that like
[ __ ] like like any guy here's the
other thing too if somebody was gonna
[ __ ] slam you like that and said well
in that case you should have cloned
yourself there's no way I'm saying why
is that cuz that's given him the [ __ ]
open door to the slam hey dude no way
I go like this alright whatever bro get
out of here and then he can't say the
thing dude you think I'm wrong too
you think I'm wrong you wonder if we
could be mad with me take it up with
Jesus Christ dude so take it up with
Jesus Christ and take it up with Christ
dude hey that's what I'm a definitely
man ooh argument stop her I take it up
with Christ that's what I'm gonna say to
wallbrook that's what I'm gonna say to
Wahlberg when we get him you know you
don't [ __ ] talk to me like that hey
dude really take it up with Christ that
would probably get him because you know
he's religious I don't even know if he
was a little but you know he's religious
it's from Boston everybody in Boston
they're the most religious people in the
world dude it's so [ __ ] Irish dude